الوعي بقضايا البيئه بدات منذ الثوره
الصناعيه الكبرى وبعدها وكن من من من من
نهايه القنه الثامن عشر ثم امتدت على من
على القناه التاسعه عشر ثم بدا العلماء
يفكرون في كبح جماح هذه الغازات التي
تنبعث في الغلاف الجوي فبداوا بدات تتاثر
همم
الكوكب الام مثل في مقدمتكم فاصبحت هناك
عدد من المؤثرات على بيئتنا من خلال
التلوث
التلوث هو السبب الرئيسي في عمليه يعني
التوجهات البيئيه المحموده التي تستهدف
همم حياه صحيه نظيفه لسكان هذا الكوكب همم
بعد ذلك همم
جاء همم
الطاقه فبدات الطاقه تستخدم بشكل كبير جدا
همم بالضبط صار هناك همم مدخلات على هذا
النظام البيئي صارت هناك مؤثرات على
الغلاف الجوي
وكذلك على الشواطئ وعلى الحياه البحريه
وعلى النظام الايكولوجي وعن النظام الحيوي
بشكل عام اا ثم جاء منتصف
تقريبا في الخمسينات من القناه الماضي
فاصبحت المدن تعاني من الملوثات خاصه بان
استخدام الفحم فاصبحت الحياه لا تطاق في
داخل هذه المدن واا
الجميع يستطيع ان يرى ذلك من خلال
الفيديوهات
تواصل الاجتماعي عن المشاكل التي كانت في
اوروبا خاصه في لندن في مدن لندن وفرنسا
وكذلك بعد ذلك اتجهت هذه الدول الى
استخدام الوقود والتركيز على الوقود
الاكثر من ضمنها الوقود
الاحفوري انه اتجهوا يعني انتقلوا من
استخدام الفحم الى استخدام النفط كبديل
وهو افضل مقارنه بالمنبعاثات التي كانت
تصدر من الفحم فاستمرت الحياه واصبحت هناك
همم دراسات همم يعني تعنى بحمايه البيئه
والتقليل من همم
الى وعي سياسي او ضمن دوليه وراينا معاهده
باريس الان حتى في مؤتمر قمه الاسير
الاخير قضيه المناخ تحت الحيز كبير يعني
من الاجنده الدوليه لكنها بدات بعد نهايه
همم
الحرب البارده
عام 1988 بدات هناك التركيز على البيئه
فيعني كانت تاتشر طرحت موضوع همم المواجهه
في همم همم مواجهه التغير المناخي همم
بعدها في 89 ااا تشكلت مؤتمر الاطراف همم
ومن ذلك الوقت بدات عمليه التركيز على هذه
القضيه